salut à tous aujourd'hui on est samedi
c'est le jour du master classe le
masters classes spéciales règles de
grammaire ne partez pas je rigole c'est
une blague je vous avais promis que ce
master cas cela serait consacrée au col
dressing c'est le premier d'ailleurs qui
sera consacrée que le trading j'en ferai
sûrement un deuxième voire un troisième
dans l'année parce que là il ya matière
à en parler on va dire c'est
l'introduction conrad huey locaux à
reading c'est quoi très bonne question
jamie littéralement en anglais ça veut
dire lecture à froid le contraire c'est
au trading est aussi le stock reding qui
est autre chose je vous en parlerai une
prochaine fois que le col reding c'est
le fait de voir une personne et de
l'observer pour déduire des choses sur
elle sur qui elle est sur ce qu'elle
pense sur son état émotionnel sur son
parcours social sur ses attentes dans la
vie où elle va d'où elle vient aussi
aussi pragmatique que ce soit où elle
était juste avant d'être là c'est
vraiment voir une personne dont on ne
connaît rien essayé de déduire des
choses et c'est tellement passionnant à
faire le plus grand col de raiders que
vous connaissez c'est charles comme ce
alors que issus de l'imaginaire de conan
doyle mais qui lui a été inspiré par un
professeur à lui qui était comme ça en
fait qu'ils observaient et qui
détruisait des choses et c'est comme ça
qu'il a créé inventé ce personnage c'est
très intéressant parce que dans les
ouvrages de sherlock holmes
on apprend aussi toute une mécanique
pour faire ça c'est pas c'est pas
réellement un manuel
mais c'est vraiment intéressant de lire
donc le but du jeu dans le col de
reading c'est d'observer et de déduire
évidemment bonjour à tous ces terribles
saragosse de pierre cros dès qu'on dit
évidemment on pense à beaucoup d'autres
atouts sa chute et est donc évidemment
le col de reading ça demande une bonne
culture générale le mentalisme au global
demande une bonne culture générale ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut apprendre des
choses dans des articles mais dit tout
le temps je jamais fait ça soyez curieux
de tout en permanence demander des
détails sachez savoir dire que vous ne
savez pas comme ça vous allez en
permanence des explications qui viennent
à vous intéressez vous à tous et ça
facilitera tout ce que vous allez faire
dans le mentaliste le plus compliqué
dans le code reading donc je disais tout
à l'heure c'est de s'entraîner alors
pour s'entraîner il ya des spots évident
au départ ce sont les lieux publics
c'est le fait de se poser à une terrasse
d'un café et d'observer un petit peu les
gens aussi dans un parc ou dans les
transports en commun très bon ça aussi
alors qu'on soit bien clair fait le
discrètement parce que quand vous allez
commencer à vous poser pour regarder
fixement une personne pendant 10 minutes
15 minutes 20 minutes pour essayer de
détruire des choses surtout dans les
premières phases d'entraînement
on met beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
temps on a tendance à se rapprocher
on a l'air un peu ch joue comme ça le
but n'étant pas de finir au commissariat
parce que là vous aurez tout le temps en
fait de de déduire votre compagnon de
cellule et vous n'allez pas aimer ce que
vous avez déduire soyez discret et
rentrer dans un processus d'observation
pour essayer de savoir et comprendre un
maximum de choses sur la personne je
vous donnais ma propre méthodologie en
premier j'essaye de déduire l'âge de la
personne
en déduisant son âge je vais déjà
connaître un petit peu ses attentes dans
la vie les attentes
c'était là au type est en fait je pars
quand même sur deux sur des constats de
base et après j'affine si la personne à
30 ans je sais qu'elle est plus dans sa
phase de réussite sociale
imaginez vous quelles peuvent être les
priorités d'une personne à cet âge là
quelles peuvent être ses peurs ses
angoisses dans quelle réalité elle
ensuite plutôt que de s'intéresser
directement la personne je m'intéresse
tout de suite à tout ce qu'il ya autour
c'est à dire les objets les accessoires
qu'elle peut avoir est ce qu'elle est un
parapluie si oui il est comment est ce
qu'un livre dans les mains
est ce qu'un journal dans les mains dans
ces cas là c'est quel journal est-ce
qu'elle a des sacs de courses et là des
sacs de courses on jauge aussi assez
rapidement si elle a fait des courses
pour un bourg de aussi à des enfants
dans le tas si vous voyez son téléphone
vous allez voir la marque ça veut aussi
dire pas mal de choses aussi voir s'il
est très abîmée pas trop abîmer ça aussi
c'est significatif essayez de voir tous
les accessoires qui a autour
avant de vous intéresser complètement à
la personne en elle-même ensuite je
regarde les extrémités de la personne
par cette extrémité là vous vous égarez
que commence par regarder les cheveux de
la personne ça en dit long ça nous donne
des détails sur le fait qu'elle ait eu
le temps de se préparer ou pas le matin
que ce soit un homme ou une femme un peu
importe ça permet aussi de voir à quel
point la personne essaye de prendre soin
d'elle et soin de son image en fonction
de la coupe de cheveux est ce que c'est
bien taillée mal taillée ça permet aussi
de voir si la personne prend soin d'elle
ou pas en fonction
ça marche pour les hommes et pour les
femmes d'ailleurs de la taille des
racines si la personne a une couleur
selon mon coiffeur hermès que vous avez
vues dans une vidéo déjà au début de
l'année que les cheveux poussent en
moyenne d'un centimètre par mois donc si
vous voyez 3 cm de racine c'est à dire
que la personne ça fait trois mois
qu'elle n'a pas fait sa couleur donc ça
veut dire que soient les stresser soit
la pâle temps soit là des problèmes
financiers peut-être en tout cas ça vous
donne encore une information
supplémentaire de la même manière je
focalise assez rapidement sur les mains
et sur les ongles ou parce que les mains
et les ongles à 10 beaucoup de choses
sur une personne déjà six ans
ça n'avait l'ongle jolie ces personnes
qui fument s'il ya eu d'alliance ou s'il
n'ya pas d'avion s'il ya des bagues s'il
ya des baraques de quelle qualité que
cécilia la montre est ce que ce sont des
mains qui sont toutes lisses est ce que
sont les mains de travailleurs qui sont
remplies dans pool tout comme les
vêtements
est-ce que les vêtements de la personne
sont assorties ou pas est-ce que ça va
bien ensemble est-ce que c'est réfléchi
à ce que ces faits aient goût est ce que
ça a été pris un petit peu au hasard
dans l'armoire est ce que la personne
est habillée de manière un petit peu on
va dire un petit peu coquette
ou alors est ce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on l'obligent à porter peut-être pour
le travail
si la personne je vous prends un exemple
concret là parce que j'ai eu il ya pas
longtemps personnes qui étaient en
costume et on était le matin est
vraiment la chemise était mal mise mal
rentrer mais c'était pas grand chose
c'était juste assez pour savoir que la
personne était parti à la bourre de chez
elle donc ça veut dire que la personne
n'avait pas entendu son réveil et vu les
cernes qui avait sous les yeux et les
mains était encore un petit peu sale
surtout au niveau des ongles je pense
que la personne elle avait fait la fête
la veille et que le matin elle s'est
réveillée et java lui d'enfiler le
costume en speed et partir je pense que
l'étape douche même a été sauté et la
chemise était mal rentrer enfin oui un
tout petit détail peut en dire long sur
ce qui s'est passé précédemment tout ce
que vous allez pouvoir voir essayer de
les interpréter seuil et d'émettre des
hypothèses
elles seront souvent je ne sais pas
extrêmement dur à faire le col de
reading c'est juste qu'on prend pas le
temps d'observer on prend encore moins
le temps d'essayer de faire des
déductions ce qui serait d'ailleurs
formidable c'est de pouvoir après aller
discuter avec la personne pour essayer
de voir à quel point on avait raison ou
pas en fait
est-ce que 75% des hypothèses étaient
bonnes est-ce que 100 % ou 0 % c'est
compliqué vous à vous si vous êtes dans
un parc ou une terrasse d'observer
quelqu'un 20 minutes que la personne
commence à flipper d'aller la voir pour
vérifier mais c'est tout à fait faisable
en soirée ou quand vous rencontrez
quelqu'un que vous connaissez pas chez
des amis pouvaient observer la personne
tout un moment et puis après dans la
soirée essayé de lui parler il faut
quand même que je termine le listing que
moi je suis habituellement il ya aussi
les chaussures à regarder c'est très
important les chaussures ça en dira long
parce qu'au delà de la marque de l'état
des lacets comment c'est fait et c'est
il ya aussi tout ce que vous allez
pouvoir voir sur la chaussure et sous la
chaussure peut vous intéresser surtout
sur les chaussures des mecs et dans les
choses annexe mais qui pour moi font
partie du col trading peut-être pas pour
tout le monde mais moi je trouve que
c'est vraiment important il ya déjà le
fait de prendre conscience que la
personne que vous observez aller à
l'endroit où vous êtes vous aussi à
cette heure-ci ce jour sic et ça aussi
c'est un sens pourquoi elle est là
pourquoi elle est là et pas ailleurs
essayer de répondre à ça c'est
intéressant et enfin vous pouvez choper
toutes les aires
formations possibles et inimaginables
c'est à dire un bout de conversations
quelque chose de très significatif sur
un tatouage un ticket de métro qui
traînent toutes les informations que
vous pouvez prendre le plus rapidement
possible du regard sont intéressantes
si vous entraîner à faire ça vous allez
vous améliorer à terme ce qui est aussi
cool à faire c'est de regarder une
personne assez peu de temps de regarder
ailleurs et d'essayer de faire les
hypothèses sans la regarder plus de la
re regarder pour voir si les hypothèses
que vous et métiers de mémoire sont
toujours bonnes de visu voilà je pense
que cette première vidéo au niveau de
tout ce processus d'entraînement là est
sûre qu'est ce que le cold reding est
suffisante pour commencer prenez le
temps déjà de faire ça et après on ira
plus loin ensemble je veux quand même
vous recommander des bouquins pour ceux
que ça intéresse ces trois bouquins que
j'ai lu j'essaie aussi de taper dans les
moins chères vous met tout dans les
biens de toute manière il ya l'édition
complète de charles comme ce qui est
sorti en format numérique
vous pouvez le lire sur votre ordi ou
sûr sûr sûr les tablettes
c'est sorti j'ai vu ça il n'y a pas très
longtemps pour un euro 0,6 en format
numérique donc si vous avez une tablette
pour le lire aussi vous aimez bien lire
sur leur dis moi c'est pas toujours
forcément mon cas je vous mets le lien
dedans faites-le je pense que c'est la
bible le col grabbing au format papier
il ya aussi un livre de poche qui
regroupe les quatre grosses histoires de
sherlock holmes parce qu'en fait
sherlock holmes six à quatre grosses
histoires et après c'est une quarantaine
de nouvelles et enfin un livre qui est
parfait aussi pour commencer le collage
adding par faire alors il n'ya pas le
mot cold reading dessus c'est le livre
de david lieberman qui s'appelle lisez
dans les pensées de votre interlocuteur
je crois je vous mets aussi le lien dans
le commentaire
voilà j'espère que ça ça vous servira
aussi parce qu'on m'a demandé de source
et un peu les vidéos ou au delà de les
sources est en tout cas d'essayer
d'ouvrir pour ceux qui voulaient
vraiment se documenter un peu plus
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo c'est
vous qui m'avez demandé par les du col
de reading donc j'espère que ça vous
aura plu si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas
de laisser un petit allez-y déduisez ce
que j'attends pour voir pas facile ou
pouce en l'air vous pouvez également
vous abonner à la chaîne si vous voulez
vous regardez les anciens masterclass je
vous mets une petite fiche ici et
n'oubliez pas que le mental va axer et
vidéos par jour tous les jours pendant
un an de plus 1er janvier rendez vous
demain à 11 heures parce que demain ce
dimanche à 11h pour le prochain mentale
blog charme